la stratégie des bleus après les
dernières nouvelles plutôt rassurantes
pour zinédine zidane aimé jacquet a mis
sur pied un véritable plan de bataille à
un camp français qui se veut très
confiant reportage de dominique
chanteloup et gilles jacquier dans les
sous-bois de clairefontaine aimé jacquet
a le sourire il a retrouvé tout son
monde
zidane souris tous pas de problème les
tests du matin sont rassurants il est
bon pour le service je serai prêt jeu de
toute façon c'est pas c'est pas de
cheveux qui montpetit me remettez je
crois que j'aurais tout fait pour pour
être présents coquitlam présents sur le
terrain présent devant le but marqué au
mieux pour le plaisir c'était le but du
jeu est aujourd'hui histoire de re créer
de bonnes habitudes ou peut-être de
réveiller des vocations endormi bride
l'occasion de travailler un peu plus les
coups de pied arrêtés
c'est évident que beaucoup de matchs
règlement sur les coups de pied arrêtés
parce que les équipes ont été très
proches les unes des autres
donc nous on a un gros potentiel lundi
joueur de grande taille
on a des bons tireurs des bons centreurs
donc à partir de là on doit en profiter
des matches serrés qui bascule sur un
coup de pied
voilà la rançon du haut niveau et dans
le huis clos de l'entraînement du soir
c'est la tactique que l'on peaufine à
l'abri des regards
je pense que ça va être notre force et
si u 6 6 ont reçu bien autre coup je
peux vous garantir que ça soit une
grande réussite pour nous dans cette
partie d'échecs qui se prépare le je les
trouve pas toujours son compte
ne dit on pas qu'aujourd'hui les matches
se gagnent beaucoup avec le physique
beaucoup aussi avec la tactique et à
l'occasion seulement avec un peu trop de
bois